hey what's up my name's samuel leech and
i'm amanda and this is the samuel and
amanda show where we talk about money
marriage and life who wouldn't want to
know about money i mean money's great
marriage marriage is even better than
money
and life so we're going to be literally
sharing from our perspective behind the
scenes kind of stuff that i don't
normally talk about on youtube and if
you like our channel then this is your
opportunity to like and subscribe as
well so you can keep seeing more good
content on this channel
and we are going to be talking about in
this video
or this podcast we're going to be
talking about education what do you mean
by that education so educating yourself
our kids at the moment we're going
through um our first child is going to
be going to school next september so a
lot of decisions lots of decisions to be
made on that front yeah yeah also as
well here's the thing with education
okay education
is the whole school curriculum it
doesn't teach you about money it's
designed to get you in a job so i am a
little bit i would say
anti-establishment of the way the
education teaches i'm not auntie what
exists i think what exists is great but
i'm really really really keen to see
more i want to see kids talk about money
in school so they understand the
difference between assets and
liabilities good debt and bad debt so
it's really interesting as someone that
didn't enjoy school you you got one at
school yeah i enjoyed school i think
we're opposite in that way opposite in
that way yeah what are we gonna what
kind of path are we gonna push our kids
down so in this video we're gonna be
talking about the pros and cons and our
grapple with what's best state school
private school or home school what's
best if you've got an opinion we need to
know right yeah please do let us know
because i think it's quite interesting
there is those three options and it'll
be good to know what the pros and cons
are what you guys thoughts are
is there even a fourth option that we've
not even yeah maybe there is so
confident actually there is
flexi score which is kind of part-time
at home school and then part-time um
normal school that's another option so
another bit of birth it's a bit of
butter yeah all right fine so we have
been down to open days with private
schools state schools and obviously we
know about homeschooling my sister
homeschools her kids and does a very
very good job of that so firstly let me
talk about my experience listen when we
went to that school yesterday yep
in beckensfield the kids
i was looking at the kids and i was just
thinking
they're so posh and they're so polite
if we send our kids there
our kids ain't gonna be nothing like me
nothing
no i'm not saying that's a bad thing
maybe it's a good thing
there'll be nothing like that yeah they
were very different like very
very different
it's interesting because
you're very outspoken and
you know like out there they were very
much like i don't know if almost maybe
in those in a private school you kind of
almost put into a mold and then you fit
it and then it's like this is how you're
supposed to act because you're so not
like that i'm so not like that i'm so
not like that
but you could say it's fitting into a
mold or you could just say it's good
etiquette yeah etiquette i think because
i i'm trying to think if i was i was i'm
naturally more like i'm not like you and
that they're very nice yeah they were
very very nice i'm not nice i'm not nice
but do you think that's nice
nice leads to poverty
nice leads to poverty nicest
you know i mean honestly there was this
one situation i have my boy there luke
and he's two and he like runs around
really boisterous and at this price no
other parents brought their kids i know
no the parents brought their kids which
i thought was really weird because if
your kid's gonna be going to the school
wouldn't you want them to come and see
but anyway maybe they left them at home
with their private nanny yeah probably
so so so we go to the school
and
luke
and the kids show you around yeah which
i thought was actually really sweet
really really impressive so there's two
little girls they're like nine and ten
years old right they're showing me and
amanda around touring us around the
school
and luke
we've got luke we've got ruby we've got
jessica the three of us the five family
of five walking around
and luke my little boy is going crazy
running around knocking things down and
um
and one of the little girls is like
trying to you know feeling responsible
for our kid look like all right and i
said oh sorry he's a little bit a bit
hyper today and she said oh no i'd have
been the exact same at his age
i was just like i just
everyone was like that they weren't they
spoke like many adults in in one way i i
did find it really interesting and just
like wow they were just so mature for
their age so that's private school bam
bam bam bam bam no
you know what
what do you think amanda about about
what do you think about our kids going
to a super private school and being rich
and and being posh and being well like
me
it was just the opposite
absolute opposite yeah i mean i think i
think a lot of it's to do with
personality and i think we'll see with
our kids like already i think ruby would
be fine in that sort of setting um i
think she'd fit in whereas we know luke
is is different he's similar to you so i
think he might struggle being in such a
formal and you know it feels over there
we went to an all-girls school so we
probably couldn't get to luke there yeah
but oh i'm not really sure i don't know
what i think about it i feel like the
reason i became an entrepreneur in the
first place and the reason i became so
successful is because
i almost didn't have a choice because i
failed in school and because it was just
like and a lot of the teachers didn't
believe in me and this but that is not
going to be the case is it with our kids
no it's gonna be completely different
they're gonna have the best education
and the best so it's like
i just i'm i'm really not sure what i
think about everything do you think with
entrepreneurship do you think sometimes
it's naturally what's within you and
then i think it's about your
surroundings your environment
yeah what you're told what you're taught
what you believe 100 well i think our
kids are going to have a lot of that
from home and then i think it's good to
have the option of good education as
well and then depending on what their
interests are because they might want to
be a doctor which obviously you have to
go to university for or they might then
just think actually i want to you know
be an entrepreneur however i do think
the kids although they were very posh
and very nice i do think that they
actually were good kids yeah yeah
wonderful kids i also think that it
depends on what luke wants to do man
when he when he grows up and what the
kids want to do like i started from
scratch it might be that our kids we
train them to come on and take on roles
within the existing company
you know so it could be that it's just a
different thing a different setup yeah i
think so
it'd be really interesting what do you
think guys
help us out help a brother and then
state school
stay in school here's the problem i have
with private school i always thought
private school would be great state
school and private school in beckham's
field almost feel like the same thing
because the state schools are so good
their little village schools they're
really nice they're really good
education so it's like what's the point
of paying
12 15 000 pounds per kid per year
to go to a private school when they can
just go to a nice state school which
almost to me feels very similar
but what do you think but you were
pushing for private yeah well i was just
really i was i was just really impressed
at the resources and facilities that
they have in the school in private
i was moving to a few private schools
yeah i was shocked right around the area
how much they have and how much
one-on-one time they have with the
teacher so for example they have like
private one-to-one piano lessons for
example which you wouldn't have in a
state school um so i i think it was just
just the range of different things that
they can get into yeah um what about
home schooling
homeschooling is interesting because i
actually follow someone who um has
chosen to homeschool and obviously
tiffany at homeschools and i do think
it's really really interesting it's not
for me i don't think i'd want to do it
but it's very full-on isn't it it's very
good though very very full-on what's the
point of becoming financially free and
having lots of time and
isn't the purpose to then be able to
spend invest your time and raise your
kids you know what i'm saying no but so
one other thing is that we love to
travel a pro of homeschooling is that
we'd be able to travel anytime because
we're not in term times however i think
if we did home school which i don't
think we would we'd probably just hire
someone a tutor to come to the house and
teach them so then why not just tell
them yeah i don't i don't think we would
do it ourselves really yeah
so yeah yeah probably probably i think
traveling is the biggest thing so it's
either state school or private school
but then obviously on top of that you're
gonna invest in your kids you're gonna
raise them you're gonna work with them
so that they're also getting the
training about entrepreneurship and
money at home and then the academic
stuff at school so
home school
is out according to amanda oh i think
homeschooling i think there's a lot of
merit to homeschooling i think it's
really good um raising your kids is one
of the most important things ever to let
someone else do that oh it's a big yeah
it's it's like yeah it's a big thing and
the state often as well
sometimes the philosophies and the
opinions and the agendas of the
government gets pushed down into the
curriculum you've got to be super
careful you can't just send your kids to
a school and not think about it but at
the same time if school sucks maybe it
will force them to be an entrepreneur
so badly in school i don't know what do
you think comment below this is
education this is school we want to see
their comments yes we want to see them
now so comment down below so we know
don't forget smash the like button
subscribe and we will see you next time
see you guys bye
[Music]
you